hi in this tutorial I'm going to show
you how to develop a web application
using node.js and the expressjs web
framework we will then deploy our
application to AWS using elastic
beanstalk environment we will develop a
landing page where we collect and manage
sales leads you can freely use the
resulting source code as a starting
point to develop your product and we
will cover all of the concepts that you
need to know to build a fully fledged
web application using node.js we assume
intermediates programming knowledge but
no background in web application
development or no js' okay let's get
started so a little bit of background on
node.js many years back developer Ryan
dole explore the idea of using
javascript for server-side programming
with the main motivation that existing
HTTP servers could not handle lots of
simultaneous connections efficiently
meanwhile also Google's Chrome browser
team developed a new JavaScript engine
from scratch called v8 and the unique
property of v8 is that it was built to
be much much faster in interpreting and
running JavaScript compared to the other
browsers and not Jas took Google's
optimized v8 JavaScript engine for
server-side programming also creating a
setup that allowed for much more
scalable handling of requests and also a
package manager or managing the open
source JavaScript libraries was
introduced called NPM and nodejs was
born now before we install node.js we're
going to start by installing a script
called nvm so go ahead and type env m in
your browser and click on this link
nvm is short for node version manager
it's scripts to manage multiple active
node.js versions on a single computer so
let's go ahead and scroll down to copy
and paste the install scripts for a VM
and we'll paste it on our terminal now I
already had an VN installed so this step
may take a little longer in your case
and what you need to do is close and
reopen your terminal so that the in VM
script can initialize while your
terminal starts you can check that your
installation was successful by typing in
VM
- - version we're now ready to install
no js' or let's go back to node.js org
we're interested in the long-term
support version of node.js and as of
this video it is ten-point 15.0 is the
version that we need so we go back to
our terminal and type NPM install 10
15.0 this step may take you a little bit
longer you should have now no GS
installed and being actively used just
for the sake of showing you how it works
you can also install other node.js
versions let's go for 8.11 dot 3 for
example and you can switch between
node.js versions by typing nvm i use so
let's switch back to using node.js 10.15
dot 0 now for our application we're
going to use Express J's so let's go
ahead and visit Express J Escom
expressjs is a web framework and the
power of it is in its simplicity you can
develop very complex web applications
yet it is a minimalist web framework
that is very easy to grasp and this is
the install commands for expressjs but
we're going to use another tool called
the Express generator that will give us
a good starting points and a directory
structure so let's go ahead and copy and
paste this command you know directory to
install Express generator now here in
this command NPM as I mentioned is the
node package manager we will use this to
install packages and here the dash G
stands for a global install which means
the installation is going to happen the
computer wide and not just one
particular project so I'm going to press
ENTER now and now we can go ahead and
run express generator to generate our
application and useful directory
structure so I'm going to copy paste
this command here - - view equals pod
means we're going to use Park as our
HTML template in engine so I'm just
going to press ENTER and we have now
created a directory structure for our
application now that we have generated a
skeleton directory structure for our
application I want to go
each folder we created so let's go ahead
and start our text editor and let's take
a look so under my app the public folder
contains our assets assets our static
files that your HTML files makes
references to each HTML file will refer
to certain images such as logos and some
JavaScript files that need to be run on
that web page or style sheets that
describe the style on a web page the
Ralphs
folder contains the router logic we will
get to routers in a little bit and it's
one of the key parts of our application
and finally views contain the
representation of each individual HTML
page in our application notice that
these are named pyke files on each of
them get converted to separate HTML page
the bin the WW file contains the
initialization script for our web server
and one of the notable files is fjs this
is the main entry point for our entire
narrative application and also we have
the package dot JSON file which is a
recipe that contains the list of open
source packages we need to install to
run our application now let's go ahead
and install these packages and run our
application as it is so we go back to
our terminal
CD my app and we type NPM install we're
pulling and installing all those
packages this file contains not just the
packages that we need but also NPM
allows us to fetch all the dependencies
that these packages have and now in
order to run our application we need to
fight this command and once I press
ENTER the web server is running on port
3000 and when I visit localhost 3000 on
my browser I get to see this webpage
served if we go back to our source code
fjs is the most important file that we
care about fjs defines our web
application and node.js expressjs
applications are monolithic meaning that
every piece gets put together into a
single application and let's see how
that works we first import modules using
the require statements and
typically these modules are those ones
that we find under the package.json file
these modules here you will see that
they have been imported and assigned to
variable instances the one we're
interested in is this Express variable
as you see the required statements
includes the Express package assigns it
to a variable and then later on we call
the constructor for Express and assign
the result to a variable called app an
app is an instance of an Express
application typically this is a vanilla
instance and then we make certain method
calls to modify and configure our
application and also use and include
other modules here we first set that the
views are included in a directory called
views this is what this line does and we
have as you can see a fuse directory
here and next we set that we you are
going to use Punk
as our view engine so the app instance
that is unmodified and new gets modified
by these set calls and then we have
certain use method calls where we define
further configuration and further
components that we're going to use and
one of the notable ones is the index
router object that we have defined in
this project if we go up here we use the
require statements to include an index
j/s under the routes directory whatever
that has been exported from this
index.js file is assigned to an index
route or variable and this instance is
then used for the path that is slash so
this line means that our application is
going to use an index router for the
slash route and that's how we also
connect pieces of our application into
one analytic instance because indexed
router was defined here under index j s
and it has been included from fjs let's
take a look at how the routes object is
defined if we go under routes
index of joy yes again we are requiring
the Express package we have a variable
called Express and then we call a router
to create an instance of an Express
router and just as we did here the
router instance here is a vanilla
instance it hasn't been modified and
then we make some certain method calls
to define it further in this particular
case we're defining a get method and how
to handle this slash path with a
function and then we export the router
instance that we have created to be
included by another module and EPIP j/s
includes that router here and that's how
we connected and the router objects to
recap is a vanilla instance then we make
some modifications on it and then we
export it and this pattern is used
throughout the application this is how
you divide your application into
separate instances now let's take a look
at what a route handler is and how it
works here we have a router variable
that is an instance of an express router
and this router variable has several
components that we care about the first
one is that we're making a call to get
and this defines that the route handler
is associated with the get HTTP method
and then the second component we're
interested in is the path so typically a
router will match a particular path used
in a URL and then finally there is a
handler that gets called if a path is
matched to look at it more closely if
this is our URL
the first section defines the protocol
being used and the second one is the
domain and then finally after the slash
here we have a path component so a
router object will look at this path and
see if it is a match for the path that
it has in its own definition finally the
router will call the handler that's
associated with it the last bit of
detail here is that the get method here
is defining the HTTP method that this
route handler is
- it only responds to the c-can't method
if there are no routes that match for a
given path or HTTP method our
application generates a 404 error which
means not found so as a recap under
route indexed Jas we're creating an
Express instance and then recalling
Express dot router to create a router
instance and on this router were
defining that for the HTTP GET method if
we are looking for the path slash and it
gets matched we call this function as
our handler for this route and under app
dot j s we have indexed router
representing our exports from routes
slash index file and then we have this
statement here app dot use and for the
slash path we're using index router
effectively meaning that when we type
this route path with no / or / e it
means the same thing essentially and
when we press ENTER we call the route
handler that's defined here which
renders our index page and that's how
essentially our route handler works
before we dive into source code and
define routes and handlers let's cover
what an HTTP request is and how a
request sequence works the HTTP short
for hypertext Transfer Protocol defines
multiple methods for browsers to
communicate with web servers and the
HTTP methods allow the browser to take
different actions the get method simply
fetches a resource from the web server
such as a web page when we make an HTTP
GET request the server typically
responds with a resource such as a JSON
object or an HTML file and in our
current scenario we are interested in
sending back an HTML web page and we use
the Express GS specific method called
res not render the resident render will
generate an HTML page and our web server
will respond back to the browser request
with a
Paige and the other method we're
interested in is called HTTP POST this
is typically used for submitting data to
a web server when you fill out a form on
a web page and you press the submit
button the data is sent to the web
server and typically an HTTP POST method
is used there are multiple HTTP methods
and what method is to be used is defined
in the form definition on that
particular HTML page but most of the
time and almost always a post request is
used and once the server receives a post
request it does something with the sent
data such as updating a database and
then the server typically calls the res
that redirect method again this is
specific to express J's to redirect the
browser to another URL or path so the
server responds with a redirect after
processing the data back to the browser
and finally the browser will do another
HTTP GET request as a third step
fetching the route that it has been
redirected to now there are a few more
HTTP methods but this gives you the
foundation for developing a rich web
application now you know enough to
develop routes route handlers and
develop your application one of the
issues with our route handler is that
the logic that matches a URL pattern is
here but also the handler function the
handler logic itself is defined as part
of the route angler and what we want to
do is separate these two so that we have
a modular approach so we go to our
terminal and I'm going to create a
directory called controllers controllers
essentially are a collection of route
anglers I'm going to copy this function
from here and place it under controllers
in a new file save it here and give it a
name called index and save it with the
name index dot J s and if I go back to
the route defined in the
as an instance of what we have exported
from our controllers index.js file I can
now refer to the handler that I've
defined from this rod file so if I go
back to controllers as a recap we have
an index of Jas and we have a method
called index that we're exporting as our
handler and under our routes let us save
this file again and under our route we
are importing it as a variable instance
called index and we're assigning the
index handler for this route let's now
save our application restart it and see
if it will work so I'm restarting the
application and typing this URL and it's
working so controllers allow us to
separate handler logic as you see in
this example from the route handler
logic and we're going to build many more
of these controllers now let's take a
closer look at what our controller
function does so if we go under
controllers index of Jes we named our
function as index and the only call it
has is to a call called res dot render
the resident render called renders an
HTML page from a template the first
argument is the name of the template
file which is index if you see under
views directory we have a file called
index tag and the second argument is a
JavaScript object with a key value pair
the key is title and the value is
expressed now under app dot j s we did
define our view engine as pug and we did
define that the views are located under
the views directory so expressjs knows
where to search as the starting point
for view files so when we pass index as
the first argument it will go and look
at the views directory and find that
there's an index dot Park file here and
then Pug will convert this template into
a real HTML if we look at this second
parameter again title colon express we
also pass this
the parameter to pug so if you look at
index dog park it will use the variable
and replace it with its value there are
two cases where the value is being used
here we'll get to this when we look at
pug in more detail but essentially our
controller function simply renders an
HTML page it responds with a HTML page
back to the requesting browser now is a
good time to use version control and
checking all the files that we have
created by assuming that you've
installed gates and I'm going to
initialize a git repository here by
typing git init DB and we've initialized
a repository and you can check that we
have created a dot skit file in the
current directory that stores all the
files by our git repository and now I'm
going to check in all the files but
before I do that I need to create a file
called git ignore under my app let's
create that file and type node modules
in it because node modules are installed
open source files they're not part of
our project and get ignore file having
no bodies will exclude those files all
of these files from our version control
typically any file that gets
auto-generated or external to your
repository you should exclude by using a
git ignore file ok coming back to the
terminal I'm going to make my first
comments by typing git add dot dot here
representing the current directory so
I'm going to add all the files in my
current directory to the git index and
commit them by typing git commits - a
meaning commits everything that is in
the index to get so as you can see we
have a bunch of files being committed
and we're also including the git ignore
file so let's like initial comments and
save and exit and we have essentially
committed our first change to our git
repository to get the full source code
for those tutorials if you go to this
website and scroll below you will see
posts with programming snippets as well
as the link to the source code for those
tutorial
and if you have questions you can click
on this button on the same page become a
member it's free and then you will be
able to add comments to tutorials and
get answers now one of the problems we
have is that every time we make a
modification in one of our source files
we need to restart our web server
because the changes made to source files
are not being recognized and in order to
remedy this problem there's a tool
called node amount that we are going to
install so I'm going to stop our web
server and I'm going to install node 1
by typing NPM install node amount and
then also typing save - dev what this
does is the save dev will save node 1 as
a developer dependency meaning that we
only need to install it when we are
developing our application so if we go
under package JSON we now see that node
1 is a developer dependency and now we
need to modify this line so that in the
case of an environment where we're in
production we're still using the
standards node command but in case of
development we're going to run node mom
instead that monitors for changes in
source files and restarts our web server
so for the start scripts I'm gonna go
ahead and type if the environments is
production then we use node bin www else
we use nodes one being www and then fi
now this should work and we are going to
use node 1 to monitor our web server so
let's go ahead and try running this ok
as you can see no daman has started and
when we make any source code changes
it's going to automatically restart our
web server now is a good time to make a
get comments because we've installed not
much so I'm going to do git add package
JSON and then
git commit dash em install no more now
I'm going to cover the most common web
application development pattern where we
are going to build a landing page with
various routes to collect sales leads
manage them view them delete them and
edit them let's go ahead and rename the
variable index as landing because we're
going to build the landing page and our
controller is going to be called landing
and we're going to name our first method
that gets our landing page as gets
landing so if we go we save this file
and go to controllers index.js let's
let's rename this file as landing
jeaious and first function is going to
be get landing and also let's rename the
view now when we fetch this file we're
going to display a form where if a
visitor likes our service or our value
proposition they will enter their email
address and send us that information
enable so I go under views landing that
bug and right below this paragraph are
going to design a form the the form
element takes one parameter called the
action when we submit the form which
path we're going to use is defined by
action so I put a comma and for the
second parameter I'm going to use the
method called post when you submit a
form the method that has been defined in
the form is the one that the browser
will use for making the request so we're
interested in using the post method and
I'm going to define an input elements of
type email and we're going to use a
placeholder let's write your enter your
email address
notice how there is an indentation here
Park nests HTML elements by using
indentation so inside form we have
nested and input and also typically we
want to nest a button inside a form so
that the button is associated with that
form so I'm going to define a button
elements of type submit' when this is a
submit button that indicates that we're
to submit the form that the button is
nested in we're going to use a name for
the button called submit and I'm going
to now save this form so let's make sure
all of the files are saved and if I now
restart my application I should see the
form being served by the center here
right so we have this enter your email
address form with an input and then a
submit button we're also going to commit
our changes by typing its ads because we
renamed some files we need to explicitly
add what's to get add views it has
rollers let's see if we have captured
all the files I do get comments - a to
commit all the changes landing that POG
has been registered as a new file and so
his controller landing of j/s but we
missed views landing that Park so I'm
going to explicitly add that file
landing that part okay now if I commit
we should be covered with all the files
that we have renamed and added in gates
I'm going to write a commit message
landing page getting started and first
form typically what in get you first
summarize your change in a single line
and then you would leave an empty space
and then include further information in
the second paragraph but at this point
we don't need to mention much I'm just
going to leave it at the first line now
that we have defined this form we're
going to develop our first post routes
so I go to browse index j s and include
a new router with the posts HTTP method
and then I'm going to use a new handler
called
landing that submits lead because we're
looking for sales leads it is called
summit lead I'm going to save this file
go to the controllers landing dot j s
I'm just going to copy and paste this
first handler that we had and I'm going
to name the second one as submit lead
when we submit our form from landing dot
Park there is this input elements we
forgot to name it so where I'm going
define a name for it called leads email
when the form is submitted from that
browser we're going to be able to access
the value inside this input elements
with the name lead email by going to our
controller let's delete this statement
here we're going to print out the input
element that we have received lead email
and the way we do that is by using the
body parser library we are going to do
rec that body lead email to print out
the value I believe I need to include
the package called body parser in app
dot J's for this to work but it turns
out expressjs already includes this
functionality this allows us to retrieve
the values for input elements when there
is a handler for a post request you feed
simply do-rag that body that lead email
we're going to be able to access the
value inside the input element now this
handler is successfully reading this
data but we can't leave it at that we
need to conclude the request so we're
going to do read that redirect and we're
going to use the original path of slash
so that we go back to the landing page
for now so I want to save this and we're
already running the application let's
see what happens if we submit an email
address here my email at domain.com so
I'm going to press submit as you can see
the browser was redirected to the same
page but let's see what happened in our
console we were able to receive the
value and print it
let's check in all the changes we made
so let's go to our terminal and type git
add controller's landing j/s it add
routes index.js and we also modified our
view file so we're going to do git add
to use landing dot pug and comments
landing page post routes to submit email
so we're able to receive data in our
application but we're not able to do
much with it so we're going to install a
database an SQL database particular
Postgres database for our application go
ahead and open up your browser and type
homebrew homebrew is a package manager
for mac OS and one of the packages
maintained is the PostgreSQL package so
you can copy and paste this installation
script on your terminal if you're on a
Mac OS to install homebrew let's go
ahead and just do that and it's going to
install a command line tool called brew
which will allow you to then install
various packages including a PostgreSQL
now I have it already installed so I'm
going to skip this step and assuming you
have installed this we can then install
Postgres by typing brew install
PostgreSQL so after you've done that you
can start your database by typing brew
services starts PostgreSQL this is going
to start the Postgres process in the
background on your machine so that you
can connect to it and create databases
manipulate tables do things with it
so i've already run this command so i
already have a database running we're
going to use a tool called P SQL to
connect to our database and make some
changes so I am going to try P SQL
Postgres to connect and if everything
goes well you should see the poster SQL
prompt and now we're ready to create our
database first we create a user that can
access that database by typing create
role express MVP TP user I'm assuming
here that I'm going to use the name
Express MVP for our application so I'm
just adding a - DP user for that and
with login passwords make the password
simple for now and press enter and now
I'm going to create our database by
typing create database Express MVP DB in
case you want to delete these roles or
databases and redo the same command
you can do that by typing a drop
database or drop roll so we're now ready
with our database I'm going to quit psql
by doing the control D we're done with
our database setup now we're interested
in using a library for accessing our
database from JavaScript and
manipulating data and for this we're
going to use an object relational mapper
library shortly called an ORM we picked
C cool eyes as our choice of ORM if you
go ahead and type sequel eyes in your
browser we're going to find a website
for it as sequel eyes is a stable and
popular Orem for nodejs and it will work
well for most of our needs and Oren
greatly simplifies the type of queries
you have to write for manipulating
database tables and rows instead of
typing long error-prone SQL queries and
Orem lets you generate those queries by
writing javascript okay so let's go
ahead and open up our terminal again and
type NPM install sequel eyes this will
install Saku lies as a package I
recommend doing - - a safe so that it's
say - our package that JSON file we're
also interested in the database driver
library in node.js for PostgreSQL which
is simply called PG so I'm going to go
ahead and type NPM install PG - - save
as well sequel eyes will invoke PG in
order to access the PostgreSQL database
this is a low-level library for
accessing PostgreSQL databases the other
tool that we need is a command-line tool
for sequel eyes called sequel eyes CLI
so I'm going to install that as well by
typing NPM install sequel eyes - CLI and
I'm going to use - JEE
so that concludes our installation for
Postgres and a sequel eyes now we're
going to create some configuration files
so that our application and cyclists can
access our database and for that we're
going to use the tool a sequel eyes CLI
but before we start we need to first
create a configuration file for sequel
eyes CLI so that's the default paths we
use
are going to be defined let's go ahead
and create a file called dots equalized
RC in the root of our projects typing a
touch that sequel eyes RC and let's open
up our editor when we open a sequel SRC
we see certain paths defined let's
remove the DB path and let's keep it
empty for now we want to create these
directories directly under our
application root folder so that they're
accessible easier with one less step so
let's go ahead and save this file and
now we're ready to generate some files
so I'm going to buy sequel eyes in it
and we have created several folders the
config slash config dot J's is the one
we're interested in this is defines the
database details let's open up our
editor again and go to config slash
config dot J's we have three
environments defined here one for
development test and also one for
production so I'm going to type here
module that exports equals and for
developments we define the database
username as Express MVP - DP user as our
password we defined one two three four
five six and for our database these are
the users and database we created using
the P SQL command previously so we're
going to type Express MVP DB and our
host is hundred and twenty seven zero
zero one this stands for the localhost
the database we're using is Postgres so
we're going to use the dialect Postgres
here there's one more parameter missing
here the port parameter typically for a
Postgres database that is 5 4 3 2 I'm
currently not going to attach the other
environments I'm going to save this one
here so we should be now ready to access
our database from sequel wise using our
application now I'm going to go back to
the terminal to commit some of the
changes that we made so far and we
installed secret lies and the PG
libraries so we've modified our package
that JSON file let's go ahead
create a comment for that change we have
added sequel eyes and teaching packages
to save this comment we also defined a
sequel eyes that our CFO so I'm going to
add that one as well and commits this
change configuration file for sequel
eyes CLI and I've also created a
configuration file for our database
connection so I'm going to commit this
file with git add convict of Jas there
is also one more file that I'd like to
introduce to you briefly under models
when we ran seek realizing it we define
the file called index of Jas this will
initialize sicko wise when we run our
application it takes the environment
that we defined under config yes and
then creates a new sequel eyes instance
using the database credentials that we
have created so this is the
initialization file that was
auto-generated when we typed sequel eyes
in it so I'm going to check this file in
as well and the file name is always
indexed of JSON this is a specific file
just for initializing sequel eyes so I'm
going to commit these changes when we
added configuration file for sequel eyes
and the script as a recap for where we
left off we can visit our landing page
and then submit an email address to our
application and display the email
address collected as a console log now
that we have installed our database and
installed sequel Iser and configured it
we're ready to define our first model as
well as the first migration so let's go
ahead into our text editor and create a
new folder old migrations and let's
create a new file under the models
directory named lead that Jas since were
collecting sales leads our table and
model will be named leads migrations
allow us to create recipes to take our
the base states the database definition
from point A to point B for example
right now we have no tables in our
database even though it has been created
and with a migration recipe we will be
able to create our first table that
represents our sales leads and we will
run that migration to create our first
table and start accessing it and the
model definition is used by cyclists to
create to generate the methods for
accessing the table and to update the
table to take database actions on the
tables such as creating rows deleting
rows updating rows and fields and in
contrast migrations are used or
manipulating the database table
definitions themselves such as creating
a table adding a new column or changing
the type of the column in that table the
migration file that we are going to
create is highly specific to cyclist
cyclist has all level methods for
accessing and manipulating a PostgreSQL
database but the migration itself is a
file a recipe that's specific to
equalise and so is the model that we're
going to define so let's go ahead and
create a new migration file and let's
define our first table I'm going to copy
and paste this code that I have already
prepared as our first migration let's
first save this file on migrations are a
sequential in the sense that they need
to be run in order they don't make sense
if they are run without an order so we
need to order them by the file name and
we do that by including a date starting
with the year a month and the hour and
even the minutes when the migration is
created so as of now we're in January
4th 2019 so I'm going to name my
migration as 2019 zero one zero four and
then the hour is 1917 and I'm going to
include the action that this migration
is going to take which is creating a
table names lead so create leads table
and then finally that's AJ s here is our
first migration saved and the migrations
are bi-directional so
you can apply a migration represented by
the up method and then you can roll back
a migration by using a Down method so in
this case the up method stands for
creating a new table called leads with
so-and-so fields and then the down
methods or action represents dropping
the table will effectively cause the
table to be deleted from our database
now if you look at the fields that are
being generated we first obviously have
an ID field and ID represents a unique
column in our database and it's very
represented by a universally unique ID
type and sickle eyes it has that type
built in for us and typically we need a
created at and update to that field for
each row when a new row is created this
date will be relevant and each time a
row is updated this second field updated
at is going to be irrelevant and finally
the actual field the data that we were
collecting in our application is an
email address so we're including a field
called email of type a sequel eyes
string so we have saved this migration
we can go ahead and run it by typing
sequel eyes DB migrate the command has
succeeded which means we have created a
table called leads in our database now
we need to define the sequel eyes model
definition for the table we just created
so let's open our editor and create a
new file under models called
lead jeaious I'm going to copy and paste
the definition that I created earlier
for this this JavaScript model file is
specific to sickle eyes a secret eyes
will generate the methods it needs to
access the database table by using this
model definition we define an ID field
in the model which is a primary key and
then we define an email field as well
which is of type string notice how these
fields match the migration we just ran
for the leads table and we omitted the
Creator that and updated that fields in
the model because sequel eyes assumes
they always exist when we run the
application sequel Liars will
models index J s if you look at this for
each section it will go over each model
definition under the models directory to
import and use for accessing the
respective database tables under model
directory for each database table we
define a model such as the one we
created for Lita Jas for the leads table
and sequel eyes we'll go over each of
those to generate the methods so that it
can access those tables in order to
achieve this we need to go to the
initialization file being / www and here
initialize sequel eyes for that we need
to first create a variable called models
and import the models directory and
these three lines starts our servers
listening on a particular reports we're
going to modify this code a little bit
and we're going to type return models
that sequel eyes sink and then result
I'm going to cut and paste this portion
inside the body of this call okay we're
now ready to further develop our
application and run sequel eyes queries
before we go any further let's check in
the files that we have just created so
I'm going to add the migration we
created commit this file create
migration for leads table or creating
leads table and I'm going to check in
the model as well it's add models lead
jeaious
we're also going to check in the changes
we made on the initialization file bin /
www initialize secure wise now that we
have a database setup we can implement
the post routes where we will save an
email address to our database so let's
go and open up our editor and go to
controllers / landing jas we're going to
modify the submit lead Handler to save
the email address collected to our
database so let's go to the top and then
type cost models equals require dot dot
slash models models gives us access to
the sequel eyes methods for the models
that we have defined and I'm going to
try to return models that lead that
create note that create is a sequel eyes
method and for the email field we're
going to use the value we've obtained
from rick body lead email then take the
results and redirect back to the landing
page and let's delete this last line and
the first line save and rerun our
application if I go back to the landing
page and type an email address here is
your name at male comm and submit notice
that the browser reloaded the landing
page and that's because of the resurrect
here and I'm assuming that the create
call has succeeded if you go back to our
terminal we see this SQL statement here
generated by sequel eyes ran by sequel
eyes we're inserting a new role into the
lead stable particularly the
the email created that and updated that
fields new a unique ID for the role and
then the email address we just submitted
and then the dates so we've successfully
saved the email address in our database
let's commit the changes we made so I'm
going to type get adds controllers
landing jeaious and then commit to
change save leads collected landing page
we save email addresses collected back
to the database we're going to implement
the most common web development pattern
shortly known as crud which stands for
creates update and delete we've already
done the creation of leads with this
route and now we're going to define new
routes that allow us to do listing
editing updating and deleting of leads
so and the first one we'll cover is for
listing the leads so let's define a new
route with the path slash leads and the
handler called as show leads let's save
this file and let's go to controllers
landing dot j s to define our new
handler let's copy and paste the first
one we created it's name is as show
leads now all we need to do is fetch the
leads from the database and for that
we're going to call models lead that
find all and then we will be returned an
object let's name it as leads and let's
cut this line with the rest and ER and
paste it inside the body here a few
things to note this call here is a
promise and we're going to cover
promises in detail later but for now
what you need to know is that this call
is going to execute
as synchronously and the then here
ensures that the results within this
body are available after the execution
of this call has completed so there's a
guarantee that this body is going to be
available after this execution even
though the call is a synchronous and
we'll get to those later and the final
method is defined by Seco lies and also
the leads object here contains the rows
returned from the database and also the
methods to access those rows so as you
can recall the render method the second
parameter is an object passed to our
view file we're going to define a new
key here called leads and assign it the
value of our object leads and save this
file and one more thing to note is that
this video file usually typically we use
a different view file for each purpose
but for the time being we're gonna use
the same landing view file to also show
the collection of leads now let's go to
views landing that Punk we're going to
type if Leeds Park we'll check that if
the Leeds variable is nonzero it's going
to include the rest of the HTML snippets
let's type if Leeds and then let's
define a header here called text Leeds
Park also has the capability of
iteration we're going to do for lead in
Leeds
note that Leeds is an array of objects
of type elite we're going to create a
paragraph and type lead that email now
part considers that anything of that
comes after the pea is text we don't
want to display this as text and we want
to use the bug way of tag syntax of
dereferencing this variable which we
used here by typing hash open curly
brackets and then close curly brackets
let's save this landing file and go to
our terminal our application is still
so let's go to our browser and type
localhost 3000 there's one more thing we
want to do let's go back to the landing
jas controller now instead of
redirecting to the slash route we
actually want to go to the leads route
when we submit a new lead so that's the
change we make so that's the this new
route that we defined is going to be
triggered which will call this show
leads function okay so if we go back to
our browser let me submit a new email
address lead one email calm and when I
submit this I see the list of leads on
the same page and notice how the browser
went to the slash leads routes because
of the change we just made so let's
check in the changes we made so I'm
going to do get as controllers landing
J's add routes index Janus and and P use
landing the puck implements these routes
of needs submission now we want to take
a look at the details of each individual
leads so let's define a new route called
slash lead / : lead underscore ID and
let's define a handler landing that show
underscore lead now two interesting
things here firstly we defined slash
lead slash as a unique path component to
match individual leads and notice how
this path is unique and different than
the other routes we defined we will
handle all details of an individual lead
under slash lead slash path component
which gives us sort of a namespace to
work on individual leads the colon here
defines lead ID as
a parameter as a request parameter that
means whatever that comes in the URL you
type in the browser after slash lead
slash is going to be captured in a
request parameter named lead underscore
ID and we can then access the value of
this parameter in the route adler show
lead now let's go to controllers landing
j s and copy and paste one of the
handlers we already have let's name it
as show lead and what we need to do now
is query the database for a lead with a
given ID so I need to do return models
but lead that finds one and then the
where clause helps us query for a
particular field and we're going to use
the ID field and we're going to pass the
request parameter that we received named
as lead ID to find the particular lead
record in the database corresponding to
our lead now this will return a lead
value let's go ahead and delete this
portion and here we're going to do res
render we're going to define a new view
file called lead and pass an object with
key lead assigning it the database
object that we received now let's save
this file and go ahead and create a new
file under review called lead let's copy
the initial portion of landing that bug
and let's define an h1 lead header and
let's simply define a paragraph with the
lead information lead the email now
let's go to landing dot Park we want to
give the user an opportunity to click on
a link that takes us to the individual
detail
page for that link and we don't have
that link here so I'm going to add that
to this paragraph but I would like to
display both the leads email and also
that link on a single line the same line
so I'm going to nest the link and the
email under the same paragraph as a
reminder we nest HTML elements with
indentation in pug so I'm going to first
define under the paragraph a span
elements that will display our email and
also this character that I'm typing is
used for text and also to display spaces
in puck so I'm going to include one
space character and define our link with
the anchor tag with an href property of
slash lead slash and now here we already
have access to the lead object that has
been obtained from the database so we
can include the ID of the lead here by
typing Lita ID and we are going to use
the text details in the link so now this
link is going to point at the path slash
lead slash plus the database ID of the
lead so let's save this and run our
application everything seems to work
fine so let's open up our browser type
localhost 3000's let's submit a new lead
new leads at domain.com and see that
we're able to display both the leads and
also the details link for those leads
I'm going to click one of them we're now
navigated to that path and we're able to
display the lead information now let's
check in all the changes we made
if ad views it adds controllers and
routes and then comment now add a new
route to display these details let's go
back to routes slash index dot J's and
we're now going to define the routes for
editing individual leads so let's type
router that gets slash lead slash :
lead underscore ID and we're going to
define a new action for this particular
lead ID which is going to be slash edit
and we're going to define a new handler
with landing that show edit lead now
this is a gate routes which means that
we're going to fetch a new web page for
the purpose of editing the lead ID so
we're going to deliver a form that
contains information about this lead ID
by using the show edit lead Handler and
let's type router that post slash lead /
: leads ID slash edits and define a new
handler called
edit underscore lead here the first
route we define shows the form for
editing the lead ID and the second route
we defined which is a post submits the
form to edit the lead ID now there's one
key point here we are highly interested
in defining the same path component for
the gates and the post routes and this
is because when an error when we handle
the post request if we re render the
same page we want the URL in the browser
to match the original get requests we're
going to go into more detail about this
when we cover error handling now let's
get started by creating the link that
will take us to the editor out for the
lead for that let's open up views lead
that bug now we're going to modify this
by creating a span under the paragraph
and we're also going to create a link an
anchor tag with an href of slash lead
slash plus lead that ID remember that we
have the lead database object available
to us so we can reference it's ID and
also we're going to add the slash edit
path for editing the lead now let's
write it is for this link and save this
file and notice how the value of this hf
property corresponds to the get route we
defined here now let's define the
handler for this show edits lead route
by going to controllers and landing j/s
and let's copy and paste one of the
handlers here and call it show edits
underscore lead now this handler also
obtains one lead record from the
database by using the lead ID parameter
and then we're going to instead of
displaying the lead we're going to
display a form where we can edit and
submit the updates on a lead so I'm
going to call this edit underscore lead
and we're going to use a directory
called lead for all the view files where
we manipulates each lead so I'm going to
finally call this lead / edit the bleeds
now let's save this controller and
create a sub folder under views called
lead and also create a new bug file
called edits underscore lead that bug
now let's go to landing that spark and
copy the beginning portion to edit lead
and now we're going to create a form
under edit lead where we will modify we
will have
opportunity to modify the lead so we can
copy some code from landing that Parkway
or where we already had a form I'm going
to copy this form and input element and
the button elements to edit plate now
the action for our form needs to reflect
the route that we define here which is
lead slash leads and then the lead ID
and edit so let's go ahead and add that
here we're going to use plus Lita ID and
then plus slash edit and the method
we're using is post method and we're
still going to use the same name as lead
email in our input it is of type email
if we need we have a placeholder if the
lead field is empty and then let's call
this button save now rather than an
empty form we want to show the existing
value of the lead so we're going to add
a new property in our input elements
called value and assign it with lead
email which we will receive from the
database now let's save this file
because this file is one subdirectory
under views because we created this lead
directory and we are referring to layout
that Park at the beginning we need to
update also our reference to go one
directory level below now if we go back
to our index J's file we haven't defined
the route handler edit underscore lead
for the post route so let's go to our
controllers landing the Jas and define a
new route called edit lead and let's
delete the body now we have access to
the leads ID by using records param
studs lead underscore ID because this
was available to us
the route path we also have access to
Greg body lead underscore email the
actual updated fields and that comes
from the edits lead form the name of the
inputs element was lead underscore email
so we're going to use these fields to
first retrieve the object by using its
ID and then we're going to update its
email fields by using lead email let's
go ahead and type return models that
lead that update email brick body does
lead underscore email and we're going to
use a where clause we're going to ask
for the ID field using rec params lead
underscore ID and our query is complete
then once this field has been updated
we're going to receive the results as
how many fields has been updated from
cyclist we're going to redirect the user
to view the lead so we're going to use
slash lead slash plus reg params lead
underscore ID so this way after the post
is successful and update is done we're
going to be redirected to this route
that shows the details of the lead now
let's save our controller and run our
application and see how it works so I'm
going to open up the terminal the
application seems to be running okay
and I'm going to open up the browser and
browse to localhost 3000 let's create a
new lead hello and get buzz that I owe
and submit that so we have a collection
of leads displayed let's click on one of
them and
click Edit we're now on the edits route
and I'm going to shorten this to let's
say a ATS be calm and save it and I'm
redirected to the TRO leads route that
shows the updated leads so this
concludes our tutorial on editing and
updating leads now is the time to go
back to our terminal and checking the
changes we made so I'm going to type git
add views and controllers git add route
these are the directories that be
modified and then we're going to
comments as leads edit and post browse
the next route we're going to implement
is the delete routes let's go back to
our editor routes slash index dot JSP
the posts slash lead /li ID slash we're
going to use the delete path coupons and
then let's define a new handler called
leads underscore lead let's save this
file and then go to controller slash
landing dock GIS and let's create a new
handler for the delete action let's call
this delete lead we're going to delete
the row in the database representing
this lead so we're going to type return
models lead destroy where ID is wreck
param studs lead underscore ID then
redirect back to the landing page
because we are going to delete the
current lead and everything associated
with it
building the page that shows the lead so
that's my press that redirect slash
leads now let's save this file but let's
go to views lead lead that bug let's
define a new action here we're going to
use a button instead of a link because
the default method for accessing the
link is a get request but we're
interested in doing a post request so
I'm going to define a form here action
will be slash lead slash meetup ID /
delete and Method will be post we're
going to have a button of type equals
submit and we're going to call the
button delete let's also create some
spacing and we're now ready to run our
application let's go back to our
terminal the application is running
let's make sure we've saved all the
files and try it let's go through slash
leads let's go to the details or the
first one we do have a delete button now
let's click on it the entry was deleted
let's try it again
okay this one was also deleted let's
take a look at our database activity
we're deleting from leads
we're ID is this ID this concludes our
implementation of the delete routes as
usual let's check in the changes we made
we're going to do
and controllers it's and routes we add
views comments implements delete route
or leads in this tutorial we're going to
learn how to implement Ajax requests and
get started with using javascript in the
browser we're going to implement the
delete lead functionality using
client-side JavaScript so let's start by
defining our routes with router does
post / lead / lead ID delete and we're
going to name this as delete - JSON and
we're going to define a new handler
delete lead JSON let's save this file
and go to controllers landing dot J's
we're going to copy the delete lead
Handler we created previously and we're
going to name it as delete lead
underscore JSON we're still going to
destroy a lead using the request
parameter lead ID but then after that
instead of redirecting to the slash lead
throughout we're going to send back a
JSON object and we will do that by
typing res dots and defining a key msg
with a value success now let's save this
file and go to view / landing dot Park
we're going to implement a button that
will invoke the Ajax request that will
delete the particular lead so let's
define a button with the text delete and
we're going to define the onclick
property of the button to call the
JavaScript function delete lead on click
is an event that gets fired in the
browser when this button is pressed and
by assigning it at handler we make sure
that when the button is clicked this
JavaScript function will get called now
when we insert inline JavaScript like
this inside Park we surrounded with this
character called the grave accident
which looks like this
tilted single quotes
we're also interested in passing this
lead the ID field to the delete lead
function but also we want Punk to
evaluate the value of it and pass the
value and in order to do that we type
dollar and then curly braces leave that
ID and we surround the results with
single quote character now I know this
syntax looks a little bit complicated
but this is the best way to add inline
JavaScript in Park also passing
variables that need to be evaluated for
those who are curious grave Accent is
this left tilted single quote now for
the implementation of delete lead we're
going to use the jQuery JavaScript
library so I'm going to include that at
the bottom of the HTML page with this
single line we're also going to add a
javascript file that we are going to
define as javascript
slash leads j/s so let's save this file
and go to Java scripts slash leads Egeus
now let's define our delete lead method
and go over the details this delete lead
function is making an ajax call ajax
allows us to make HTTP requests to our
web server using javascript also sending
and receiving data in form of JSON
objects the key point with ajax is that
the requests the web requests happen in
the background while you're on the same
web page so if you go back to our
browser let's assume that i clicked on
this delete button and it invoked our
function that makes the ajax call that
means that we're still going to be on
the same page and this URL here is not
going to change and the request to our
web server and the response will happen
in the background now let's take a look
at the parameters we pass to this
function the URL field defines the route
that we're going to call and notice how
this path matches the route that we've
defined for this purpose we have a data
type
JSON and then we typically pass the data
payload in this data field and JSON dot
stringify function is called to pack the
data into a form that's transmittable
over the network and then it gets
unpacked on the other side using another
call that matches this which is json dot
parse the type of our request is a post
request and then we define two functions
one for the success case and one for the
error case and these get called when we
receive a response from the server when
we delete delete' from our database
using the HX call we want to reflect
that the lead is removed to our user on
the browser window as well now recall
that we did not navigate from the
current URL and the HX call happened in
the background for that reason we need
to modify the currently served HTML page
for displaying in the browser we do this
dynamically in JavaScript and delete the
HTML that corresponds to the lead that
we have deleted the currently served
HTML documents visible in the browser is
shortly called
as Dom which stands for document object
model now jQuery has convenience
functions that help us manipulate the
Dom such as this remove call in this
first part here we're looking for an
HTML element with the ID of lead ID and
then we are making a call to remove to
remove it from the currently shown HTML
document now in order for this to work
we need to assign the lead ID to the
particular HTML elements we want to
delete so for that let's go to views
slash landing that bug to this paragraph
elements for each paragraph we create
for an individual leads we're going to
assign it the corresponding lead ID now
HTML documents are hierarchical and what
that means is that this paragraph is a
parent of all of these children that
have been nested inside it so if we
delete this paragraph element from the
HTML document that effectively means
that we're also deleting all the
children which includes all the details
for that individual lead so we're going
to
delete this whole thing by simply
searching for the paragraph elements
with the lead ID and then remove it from
the HTML document that's effectively
what this call is doing now a few useful
details about jQuery when you see a
dollar sign like this it means that
we're making a call to jQuery it just
means we're making a library call dollar
dot Ajax means you're calling jQuery
AJAX and this dollar and then the
parentheses mean whatever that's inside
is going to be handled by jQuery the
second detail I wanna mention is this
part here when you use this hash
character it means that you're simply
searching for an ID in the current HTML
document the Dom when we do hash plus
lead ID
it means we're searching for the
elements with that particularly tidy
jQuery we'll go and search for every
element that has an ID property defined
which is a fast way of searching for
elements in an HTML document now let's
take a look at how our application works
let's go to the slash leader out in our
browser and click on the delete button
on some of these leads as you can see
the leads are being deleted from this
current HTML page but let's see what
happens in the background so I'm going
to open up the JavaScript console to see
if you're getting results so if I open
up these result objects I see that the
message success has been received from
our server each time I delete an object
let's try it once more and also let's
take a look at what happened on our
server side as we are seeing we're doing
a post request to the delete JSON route
and also we're able to delete leads from
our database it's chicken the changes we
made I'm going to do git add controllers
and routes get add views we've also
defined a new javascript file so I'm
going to do git add public JavaScript
let's call it this implement lead delete
routes using Ajax in this tutorial we're
going to update two looks of our
application using the bootstrap CSS
framework so let's open up our browser
and search for bootstrap and click on
this link and go to get bootstrap calm
the easiest way to include bootstrapping
our project is to include hosted CDN
links of the library in our project
files CDN shorty stands for content
distribution network and there are
third-party hosts for JavaScript
libraries and we will copy and include
the links for bootstrap library in our
project for that let's go to this link
and click on the latest version and
click on download and if we scroll below
we're going to be given the links to the
bootstrap CDN let's copy and paste them
in our projects there are also
dependencies provided so let's copy and
paste them as well now in this tutorial
we're also going to learn how to
separate our park files into reusable
components and we're going to create a
header a nav bar and a footer component
that we can use across all of our files
let's create a new folder under views
called common and let's create new files
heads dot Park footer dug and nav bar
dot pocket let's go to head that pocket
like mixing head title indent head meta
charset equals beauty
title equals title part mix-ins allow us
to define common snippets and include
them in multiple Park files we can also
pass them parameters such as this title
field that gets used as the title of the
document let's go back to where we
copied the bootstrap style sheet think
cut it and paste it on head that bug and
change the syntax to Park which is link
open parentheses some properties and
then close parentheses we also need to
add some standard meta tags in our head
section so let's do that as well now
let's save this file and go to footer
tab and type mixing footer footer for
the time being we're just going to
include the JavaScript files so let's go
back to where we copied the bootstrap
JavaScript files cut and paste them on
this file we're going to change each
script tags syntax to use the Pug syntax
which is script and then open
parentheses some properties and close
parentheses now let's do this one as
well
now the order that these libraries are
declared mater and bootstrap depends on
these other libraries so they need to be
declared before the bootstrap
declaration so let's go ahead and fix
that order we're now ready to include
our header and footer in landing that
bug so let's go there and delete these
first few lines and type doctype HTML
HTML blankie cools en and we're now
going to include common head that Park
we're going to invoke the mixin by
typing head and let's give it a title
starter MVP we need to add a body tag
and let's indent everything to nest in
the body and then at the bottom just
before leads that J S which depends on
jQuery I'm going to add the footer
include common foot through that Park
and intermixing and we don't need this
find anymore because we've declared
jQuery in photo dot bug now let's save
this file and reload our landing page we
can see now that this is a bootstrap
enabled page now the page elements look
rather plain because we didn't add any
styling it let's conclude our tutorial
by doing some maintenance work the other
POC file that we used was lead that bug
so let's do the same thing on that file
as well we're going to copy and paste
this header section we're going to add a
body we're going to indent the body to
nest it under the body elements and
we're going to copy the footer section
to be nested inside the body and sale we
also are not going to make use of this
layout of park file anymore so we can
delete that
let's check in all the changes we made I
don't have to type get and use common
key to add views and get comments add a
common header and footer section in all
part files in this tutorial we're going
to focus on the user interface and
update the looks of our landing page
using bootstrap templates let's open up
our editor and go to view slash landing
the bug now under the body I'm going to
copy and paste a bootstrap now bar
example that I've prepared earlier this
is our navigation bar typically for a
functional component of a page like this
such as a nav bar we can take a look at
an example on the bootstrap website and
copy now when we define components in
park
the first elements you define is the
HTML element and then everything that
comes after that separated by a dot our
CSS classes CSS classes modify the
appearance of your HTML elements so in
this navigation bar first defining a
link and then we're nesting an image in
it which is going to serve as our logo
and then we have two navigation links
nested in an unordered list notice how
each HTML elements has a different CSS
class these are classes defined by the
bootstrap framework and available to us
one last point here notice how we define
these HTML elements in park but this
line does not contain beginning HTML
element and that's because this is
typically considered to be a div you can
type it like this or you can omit
and it will be assumed that the first
element is a div element we're also
making use of an image asset file or
that I copied the file under public
slash images slash file name all your
assets which are shortly static files
that never change in your application
are stored under public you can refer to
an asset file in HTML by starting with a
slash and then the folder name and then
the file name so as the root of your
asset path slash refers to your outlet
directory let's try and run our
application by reloading our home page
now we see a navigation bar two links
and a logo now as we did previously I'm
going to cut this navbar from here and
place it in a common mixin file so let's
go under views / comment / navbar that
POG we created earlier and paste this
code we're going to define a new mission
called
navbar and currently we're not needing
any arguments and I need to indent this
by one level under mixin and save the
file now let's go back to landing dot
pug and include our mixin on their body
we first need to add a header tag
include common slash navbar dot Park and
then + navbar and let's update the rest
of our page using bootstrap HTML
elements I'm going to type container and
we create a new role and then inside the
role we create a new column and the size
of that is six for a medium sized screen
we're going to copy and paste a header
and a paragraph or two for our value
proposition and let's delete these two
lines here there were a few CSS classes
that were previously prepared I'm going
to copy and paste those and we have a
form snippet as well that matches the
form we created before
let's copy this portion the contents of
the input element and let's delete this
part now let's save this file and reload
our page now we have a landing page that
has an updated look let's go back to
landing dock bug and we're going to
update the portion where we list the set
of leads for that I'm going to create a
new row and then a column with an MD - 6
type we're going to indent this portion
and I'm going to replace this portion
with a table let's go ahead and do that
now if we reiterate on this source code
if there is a variable called leads
we're showing other title leads and then
we start a table inside the table under
this tea head elements we list the names
of the columns for the table we're using
the name email for the email field and
then the actions under the tea body tag
we're listing the rows for the leads so
here for each lead in leads we're
creating a new row and then we're
listing the email for the lead and then
a link to the details also the delete
button for it
notice how we move the lead ID as the ID
property to the table row so that the
delete lead call can find which row of
the table to delete what it's deleting
the lead so as a recap if you go under
public JavaScript's leads is at Jas this
line will find the right HTML element
and then remove it and in the case of a
table this is the table row you can
check out the bootstrap documentation on
how to build tables like this now I want
to make a few fixes on the indentation
under this h1 tag we're nesting this
table and that's not correct so I'm just
going to be nest it by one level also we
want to nest this row under the
container tag so let's go ahead and do
that
that's done let's save this now a few
more changes let's go to navbar pug I
want to update the link to the leads
routes and also let's go to footer duck
pug remember when adding a dependency
for the bootstrap library we added this
jQuery 33.1 and then the slim version
turns out the slow version does not have
Ajax calls so we won't be able to make
the Ajax call under this delete lead
function so I'm going to go back to this
and delete this slim portion so we're
not referring to the full version of
jQuery that includes the Ajax calls as
well we need to delete this integrity
hash as well since this was referring to
the previous part let's save this and we
should now be ready to run our
application let's go to our browser and
reload the homepage and let's click on
the leads link and if you go down below
we see all the leads listed and let's
click one of the delete buttons to
delete them before we move on let's
checking all the changes we made so I'm
going to do get ads Boosh common get add
use landing bug and let's try doing bit
comments and let's type installed
bootstrap and update the look of pages
while we're at it I want to organize our
pages under the lead directory and I
want to remove the list of leads from
the landing page and create a dedicated
page for leads so let's go under it lead
and create a new file and save it as
leads that's we're going to copy
the first portion of our landing page
let's just copy this part and paste it
here also let's copy the footer part and
paste that as well and in this middle
section we're going to create a new
container and then a call Youm it's a
copy and paste those these are nested on
their body and Heather and let's cut and
paste the section for leads were
actually not going to use these two
lines in the landing page either so
let's delete those save it and under
leads we're going to paste the section
we don't need this if leads check
because we're already displaying a page
and let's save this file now let's go to
controllers landing dot Jas once we
submit a lead were redirected to the
lead route and once we show the leads
instead of using the landing page we're
going to use the new page we've defined
and that will be under lead slash leads
let's save this file and let's go ahead
and run our application again if I
reload this page I got an error because
the head file is located under common
and I am one directory level below with
the leads that pug file so I need to
type dot dot slash
for all the common files let's save this
file and reload our application again
and here we are on the leads page we can
now see the leads on a separate web page
let's also update the title here two
leads and I'm also going to move this
lead the Pug file under the lead
directory so let's just do that you
leave the Pug use lead lead the pug and
I'm also going to update the CSS classes
here to match the ones we use on their
leads and to use bootstrap so let's copy
and paste the code we have four leads
the plug-in to lead that bug and let's
take the section that lists the single
lead and let's delete the rest
assuming that we are going to use a
table we can update the contents of the
table to match a single lead so instead
of having four lead in leads we're just
going to access the lead we have let's
do this
the first field is the email field which
is the same here
we can change this as edit and then
delete and here we're going to have edit
plus slash edits and instead of the Ajax
call we were going to use this form
let's copy and paste that and as you
might know we're using the button using
the bootstrap CSS classes so let's
double check what we're doing the first
entry is leave that email and the second
entry is the link to slash lead slash
lead ID and then edit which matches the
link we created here and then the last
one is a HTTP POST when we submit with
this button and the path is slash lead
slash me the ID deletes so let's delete
this portion and the body let's save
this file and let's go to controllers
landing page is when we render the lead
page that is now located under the lead
slash Lee let's save this and run our
application again so I'm going to go to
the browser window if I click on the
details now
I am seeing the lead page it now has the
bootstrap classes and a table we need to
redo the same exercise with edit lead
Park although I'm going to copy and
paste code I prepared earlier because
it's repeating the same exercise
so let's delete this HTML paste this
concludes this part of our tutorial
we've migrated all of our pages to
bootstrap and also creates the separate
leads view file let's check on our
changes
in this tutorial we're going to develop
sign up and login functionality and
learn how to works let's open up our
editor and open route slash in XJS we're
going to get started by defining the
routes for login and sign up so let's
type router get slash login we're going
to use a new controller called user and
we're going to use a handler called show
login to show the login page and then
we're going to have a router that get
for sign up and again we're going to use
the user controller and type show sign
up now let's define our user controller
here as well so I'm assuming we're going
to define a controller called user under
controllers and let's save this file and
let's go to controllers create a new
file called user GS I'm going to copy
and paste code that I prepared earlier
nothing much happening here we're simply
showing the login page the view is
located under user slash login and then
we're showing the signup page with a
sign up view under user directory
we're also passing two objects to the
view file one is form data and the other
one is errors we're going to get back to
these later on for now let's know that's
for simply passing empty objects because
these views are located under the user
directory let's go ahead under views and
create a new folder called user and I'm
going to create two new files called
login the bug and sign up that park now
let's define these pages I'm going to
paste some code that I prepared earlier
for this nothing much interesting
happening here since we covered
bootstrap a little bit before but the
essence of this page is that we have a
form that's posts to the signup routes
and we're placing two input elements
here one is an email and the other is a
password and we're submitting them with
the submit button and then we have a
link at the
for the option of going to the logging
routes
now let's go to login that pug also I'm
going to paste the code that I prepared
for this it's essentially the same code
except we're posting to the loading
routes and we're passing an email and
password field as well and the purpose
of this page is to log in and then we
have two option little links at the
bottom one is to reset a password we
haven't got a route for that yet and
then we can go back to the signup route
let's save these files and go to our
browser to take a look at how they work
so this is how our login page looks and
if I click on the signup route this is
going to serve us our signup page now is
a good time to define our user model and
migration of our database so let's go to
models and create a new file called user
J s since we covered one model
definition in detail for Lee J as before
I'm going to paste code that I prepared
earlier for the user model definition
and let's go over it quickly so we're
defining a new user model B defining an
ID and then we have several fields of
type a string we have a user name first
name last name password and email now
we're not going to make use of these
first three fields so we're passing a
property along now true so that we can
create rules that have null values for
these fields and we're essentially going
to make use of the password field and
the email field and we're also passing
the property unique for email as a
constraint so that each unique user is
distinguished by his or her email
address and email is a candidate key for
this table now we need to create a
database migration that matches this
model so let's go to migrations and
create a new file and I'm going to name
this file with today's date so that it
goes in the right order in terms of
migrations and comes after the lead
table migration let's save this file I'm
also going to copy and paste codes to go
since we've covered a migration example
before so as we covered previously the
migrations have two methods one is an up
method to move the table definitions
into a new form and then a down method
that rolls back the change that's being
made in this migration we're creating a
new table called users and the fields
were creating match the fields we
defined in the model nothing surprising
or interesting here let's save this file
and go to our command line to run this
migration I'm going to type sequel eyes
DB migrate our migration has succeeded
so we have created this table in our
database and before we move on let's
check in the changes we made so I'm
going to type git add views user D pad
controllers get add routes commit
implement get route for logging and sign
up we're also going to check in the
migrations and models so for that let's
do git add models and git add migrations
and get comments
create user model and migration now
let's open up our editor and go to route
slash index dot J's
we're going to define the post routes
for login and sign up so let's type
router that post slash login user login
router that post slash sign up user that
sign up now before we move on let's
define these controller and routes as
well so let's go to controllers users
that Jas and create these two empty
handlers sign up and log in now we're
going to implement the sign up and login
routes using a node.js library called
passport J's in particular passport J's
helps us with implementing
authentication as you might guess there
are many ways to authenticate your users
you could use social networks or other
means multiple methods of authentication
and if you're interested to find out
more you can go to passport j/s that org
for more details now let's go back to
our terminal to install the packages we
need let's type NPM install passport
we're going to use an add-on to passport
for local authentication to our database
so for that let's type passport - local
we're going to use a library called
bcrypt
for encrypting our password and we're
going to use the package validator to
validate the input we make on login and
sign up browse we're also going to need
to create sessions for our users so
let's type Express - session and finally
we're going to display error messages if
login or signup fails for any reason and
for that we're going to use a package
called connect - flash so let's type - -
save and press enter this might take a
while because we're installing multiple
packages and let's check in the changes
we made so I'm going to type git - adds
package it up JSON get that package lock
that JSON and comments Express session
and connect flash now let's go back to
our editor we're going to go to fjs to
create an instance of passport let's
type let passport equals require a sport
we're also going to define the session
so let's session object equals require
Express session and let's go down below
right after this line we're going to
declare app that use session we need to
define a secret parameter for this let's
just type our new secret for now and in
the second line we're going to type apt
of use passport dots initialize and
finally app that use passport dot
session
each of these calls must be in this
given order otherwise your application
may not work because when fjs is
processed it goes line by line to
configure the app instance in a
sequential order so that's why we need
these three lines in this order now
we're interested in setting up Passport
in a separate file than a pop J's in
order not to clutter up the J's with
details of passport J s setup so for
that before we create the app instance
we're going to add one more line here
we're going to type require dot slash
passport
setup and we're going to pass the
passport object now let's save this file
and create a separate file in our root
directory called passport underscore
setup j s and save now in passport setup
juice we're going to start by defining
an empty function that we're exporting
from this file and we're passing the
passport object to it as you might see
here we're also calling the same
function with this require statements
and we're passing the passport instance
we create a few lines earlier so let's
go back to passport dot set up now
passport J's requires us to define a few
well defined API calls to function
properly the first function is called
serialized user and the second one is
called deserialize user this Stack
Overflow page explains it quite well
serialize user is used by passport J's
to save a handle to the user object in
this case it's the database ID for the
user
it's then saved to a session variable
and later on the serialize user will use
this handle to retrieve the actual
database object for the user user object
is then assigned to the user key of the
request object so that we can use it in
our controllers or routes so let's go
back to passport setup Jace and define
these functions
you realize user we're going to simply
use the database ID and for this
serialized user we're going to query our
database or pass the ID to our user and
then we're going to type models user
find one where ID is the ID parameter
and then we get the user object back if
user is null it means there's an error
so we're going to throw an error object
from user ID and else we're going to
call done now user with the user object
so we're almost done as a recap
serialize user function determines which
handle to the user object is to be saved
in the session and then the de-serialize
user will retrieve the user object using
that handle now we need to define a
strategy for passport GS to use to
authenticate our users when they log
into the application because we're going
to use email and password as the method
for authentication we're going to define
what is known has a local strategy for
passport to authenticate our users via
email and password now let's go ahead
and type let local strategy equals
require passport local this is where
this package comes into play and then
we're going to type strategy now we need
to tell passport jas that we will be
using the local strategy for
authentication for that we added
statements passport dot views new local
strategy local strategy will call its
authentication function when there is a
login form submitted via a post request
so what cool strategy needs to know
which fields in the submission contains
the username and password for that there
are two optional fields to define these
username fields in our case it's called
email
and password fields and in our case it
is called password now if you go to
login that part you will see that the
first input field is named as email
which we will use as the user name and
the second one is named as password so
when the local strategy accesses
requests body email it will consider
that as the user name and then when it
accesses request body password
it will assume that to be the password
field now we need to define an
authentication function where we access
the database and show that there is
indeed a user with this email address
and the password provided we type
function email password as done now this
function will authenticate the
parameters however we also need the
request object here and in order for
passport to pass us the request object
as the first parameter we need to give
it another option called pass reg to
callback true we're going to use this
for error handling later on now let's
define our function let's open up curly
braces and type return models user find
one where the email field is the email
parameter and then we will receive a
result which let's call as user and if
this user is now it means we couldn't
find the user so we're going to return
on error message incorrect credentials
and we need to add return done not false
and we're going to type else if user
that password is null or user has
is defined brick
flash message you must reset your
password
these wreck flesh messages will be shown
in the subsequent rerender of the page
and we're also going to type return done
now false this is another error case
finally else if we're going to define a
function that validates the password
provided is correct so let's call that
valid password we're going to define it
shortly we're going to pass the user
object and then the password provided in
the login form and let's type rec flash
message in correct credentials and this
will be entered if the password isn't
valid so I'm going to add a knot and
here we're going to type return done now
false
so we've handled all the error cases and
if we have a valid user we're going to
return done non user there may be
further errors other than incorrect
credentials being provided and we will
handle down with this catch statement in
the end for example if there was a
database error when accessing the user
model that will be caught by the
statements so we're going to type catch
error and done error false now let's
save this and let's go ahead and define
the valid password function for passport
validation we need bcrypt library so
let's type require bcrypt
actually for accessing the models the
database we also need to define the
models variable my typing require dot
slash models and we're going to compare
the past password versus the one in the
database so let's type
valid password equals function user
password and then return bcrypt compare
sync is a bcrypt function we will pass
the password in the login form versus
the user that password fields
now the passwords contained in our
database is a hash of the provided
password so that we don't keep them as
clear text so this function will also
convert the password to a hash and
compare the hash value to the one that's
being stored in the database this way if
the database was compromised the
adversary's cannot access the clear text
passwords but they only get access to
the encrypted versions we're done with
the implementation of our first Passport
login and signup strategy using the
local strategy and let's go over the API
calls again so we're providing passport
with a handle to the user objects which
is to be saved in this session and then
passport Jes will use this handle to get
the actual user object from the database
we also define a local strategy where we
tell passport J's what feels to use for
the email and password fields when
authenticating the user post requests
during authentication there may be
various errors once the database is
queried even the email and password
fields there may be multiple
authentication error cases one of them
is that the incorrect username is
provided the password field is not
present or the password is simply not
valid in such cases we return an
authentication failed message back to
the user in the successful case we pass
the user object to the done callback and
we also catch database or other internal
server errors with a catch statement we
use a valid password function call to
compare the past clear text password
with the hash that's stored in the
database we're now ready to check in our
changes so let's go back to our terminal
and type neat and
after Jas it add a sport set of J's and
gains moments a implements a sport local
old strategy using email and password
fields now that we have set up passport
J s we can go ahead and use it in our
sign up and loading routes so let's go
and open up controller slash user J s in
the side appender we're going to create
a new user by using the user model and
then save it to our database so let's
type Const new user equals models user
the bills email break body email and
password we're going to use a function
to generate the hash of the password so
let's call this function generates hash
and we're going to pass break body
password
once we build the user object we're
going to save it by typing return new
user dot save and this is a promise so
we're going to do then result and inside
the body of this promise we're going to
make a call to passport j s to
authenticate the user after sign up so
let's call passport authenticate local
since we are using the local strategy
and then we're going to define a
redirect route after the authentication
so let's type success redirect slash
failure redirect which is used upon the
passport authenticate call failing it
will call slash signup and we're going
to define a flash message failure flash
true we're also going to pass the
requests response and next objects now
in order to use the models object we
need to first define let's models equals
require dots
models
and let's define the generate hash
function Const generate hash equals
function password and in the body we're
going to use the bcrypt method hash
think so
return bcrypt hash sink password V
credits can salt sink eight so generate
hash function will take the password and
create a salted password what that means
is we're going to create a hash of this
password and save the hash in the
database now let's also define the
bcrypt object let's be crypt equals
require be crypt let's also defined
passport it goes require passport you
also need to set up passport so let's
start const my passport equals require
dot dot passport setup and we're passing
the passport instance we also will need
flesh so let's dive let flash equals
require connect flash you might be
wondering what's flash stands for flash
allows us to display an error message on
the page that's going to be rendered so
it's a one-time message that we can send
to our client now let's save this file
and run our application and verify that
the sign up works i'm going to run the
application go back to the browser and
type slash signup let's type user an
email calm and then a password and press
sign up now that we've been redirected
to the slash route it seems to be
working let's go and verify this by
going to our terminal
here we're inserting a new user to the
database with the email that i have just
typed we have also started a new session
with our application now let's go back
to our editor and implement the login
routes in login route we authenticate a
user
initiate a session with our application
for that we're going to do the identical
action as we did in sign up with
passport so I'm going to copy and paste
that code the only difference being here
is that upon failure we're going to be
redirected to the loading route let's
check the result by going back to our
browser and let's fight slash login
let's type user at email calm and then
the password and I'm going to click on
login and then redirect it to the slash
route which means the login was
successful as well and I've initiated a
session with my application now let's go
back to our editor routes slash index
dot J's and for completeness we're also
going to define a logout route so let's
type router that post slash lockouts
user dot logout and router that get
slash logout user logout for both
requests we're going to use the same
method now let's go back to controller's
user J s and define a new method called
Lobell
we can destroy our session by making a
call to rec log out and rake session dot
destroyed and we will then redirect the
user with Red's that redirect back to
the root route now it will help us to
display these routes as links in our
navigation bar also we want to know
whether we have a user session or not so
let's go to view slash navbar dot Park
to implement this I'm going to paste the
snippet that I prepared earlier
here if we are past the user variable
that means we have an active session
going on and we display that by showing
hello user email on the navbar we also
have links to logout login and sign up
routes now for this user variable to be
passed we need to define it as an input
to the navbar mixin so let's type user
and save this file and navbar is used
from the landing page so let's go to
view slash landing dot pug and pass the
user variable to the navbar mixin let's
save this file and now let's go to
controllers slash landing j/s we're
going to pass the user variable to the
render function so let's type user rec
dot user if you recall passport Jes will
populate this rec dot user field with
the user object if there's an active
session going on let's go to our browser
window to test the login and logout
routes let's go to login and type use
your pet's email com password and login
as you can see we have logged in and we
can see the user information here and
let's click on logout and now the user
session is destroyed so we don't see the
user email address here anymore now
let's go back to our terminal and check
in all the changes we made if we type
git commit dash a it will include all
the files that have been modified let's
type in plan
it's signup moving and global droughts
using passport j/s in this tutorial
we're going to learn how to validate
form input when a form is posted to our
server and how to re-render the page
with error messages when there are
errors as a recap for how we handle form
submissions let's open up our editor and
go to routes slash index.js
here we have defined a post request
handler for signup path using this user
that signup handler so let's open up
that handler by going to controller
slash user dot j s if we look at the
sign up post handler we see that we
create a new user object without
validating the input we received from
the form req body email and read body
password fields are used directly to
create the user and save to the database
we're going to change that and validate
these input fields first before saving
the data and for that we're going to
define a validator function for our form
input so let's get started by installing
the validator package by typing NPM
install the validator we are also going
to use a package called
lodash so let's add that as well and by
- - save and press enter let's commit
our package that JSON just in case we
made any changes I'm going to type get
comments packaged of JSON and package
lock but JSON okay they install later
and -
now let's go back to our editor and in
the root directory my app let's create a
new folder called validators and save
that and we're going to create a new
file called sign up top j/s here let's 5
lets validator equals require validator
say that and i'm going to create a local
function cons well date create user
fields function this is going to receive
an error object that is empty and we
will populate it as we find errors in
each form input field and we're going to
receive the form input fields with the
req parameter which is the request
object so let's like if validator is
email break body email here this mark
stands for not so if this input is not
an email then we will populate the
errors object with the key email with a
message please use a valid email so
we're going to go over each input field
like this with an if statements the next
one for us is if not validator is ascii
we're requiring that we want the
password to be made out of ascii
characters and we're going to pass the
password with recta body that password
if this doesn't hold true then we're
going to populate the errors object with
the password key to be invalid
characters in password please try
another one we also want to enforce a
password length so let's type if not
validator is length break body password
here we pass a length range object with
minimum of 8 characters and max
of 25 then again we're going to populate
the errors or the password key please
ensure that your password has a minimum
of 8 characters now we're done with this
function because the airless object was
passed into this function it will be
modified in place so we do not need to
return the errors object now other than
this basic string validation we need to
make sure that there isn't an existing
user with the same email as the address
provided in this email form field for
that we need to query the database so
let's define a wrapper function exports
validate user function tears rank type
return models user find one where email
is req body email and then we are going
to get value u if u is not equal to
mouth then
we're going to populate the email key of
the errors object email is already in
used please log in or reset your
password
now I need to introduce you a new
concept on program execution when we
define the body for validate user where
we query the database this is an
asynchronous piece of code so it will
execute sometime in the future and we
will get the results also sometime in
the future and this first portion we
defined the validate create user fields
function is a synchronous piece of code
which means each of these statements
will execute sequentially now in order
to validate the form fields we need both
this function which is synchronous and
this function which is a synchronous and
we need to mix the two together for that
we need to use a concept called promise
and make the entire body a synchronous
we're going to cover promises in the
future in more detail but for the time
being what you should know as a recap is
that this piece of code is a synchronous
and this piece is synchronous and in
order to make use of both in a single
function we need to define a promise
which wraps the entire code in an
asynchronous body so for that let's type
return new promise function resolve
reject and we're going to create the
promise body let's cut this piece paste
it here and indent it's inside the
promise and let's make a call to
validate create user fields there's rec
and they will return the errors variable
in resolve errors and let's not forget
to include the models variable so let's
go to the top and type let models
fools require toppdogg / models now
let's save this file now let's go back
to a controller / user J s and import
validate user so let's type Const
validates user equals require toppdogg
validators / sign up now let's go down
to the sign up handler and declare a new
variable let errors equals an empty
object and we're going to call return
validate user errors and we're going to
pass the req object that contains the
input fields to be validated so let's
move on and type then errors which is
going to be the result we get from
validate user and we're going to check
whether the errors variable is populated
with any values so let's type if not is
empty errors which means the errors
object has some values we're going to
call a new method rerender sign up and
we will rerender the form just as we
will render the form for the first time
using the show sign up enter except
we're going to display the error
messages that we have populated during
the validate user call so let's add the
errors variable here errors and we're
also going to pass the usual read rest
and next objects now this case covers
the case where we have errors on the
form and we will handle this successful
case here as well so let's type else
and inside the else body let's cut and
paste rest of the code and let's indent
it so this means if there is an error
we're going to re-render the form and if
not we're going to save the data to the
database there is one more thing we
forgot this is an empty function is a
call that's been provided by the lodash
library we just installed so we need to
type Const is empty
those require low - now is a good time
to define our rerender sign-up function
it's going to be identical to show sign
up with a few differences so let's copy
and paste show sign up and we're going
to make this a local function so let's
buy a Const pre-render sign up now
even though rerender sign up looks like
a request handlers such as show sign up
it's actually just a function call so
we're free to modify its function
signature with the order of parameters
being passed
normally in expressjs the request
handlers have a particular order in
their parameters in particular the
request response and next objects are
passed in that order so rerender sign up
is called from the sign up handler at
this point and we can pass the errors
object as its first parameter and we're
then going to pass that to the errors
key so that errors can be displayed on
the form when the page is rear-ended we
also have another field called form data
and form data is a name that we made up
in particular for when there are errors
on a form when we rerender that page we
use form data to pass back all the input
fields that have been modified by the
user so that let's say when there are
errors the user does not have to
re-enter the same information to the
other form fields again and again on
each time the form is re-rendered so we
saved the user time by passing back the
data that's been entered already in a
previous submission so in order to pass
the data back to form data key we are
going to use rec that's body if you
recall if we go down to the signup
handler when the form is submitted to us
we have all the form input fields
available to us in regular body objects
with the keys corresponding to the input
names such as email and password so by
passing back correcta body after
mission we are effectively passing back
all the input fields that have been
submitted to us on the form submission
so we're passing reg that body back in
form of the key form data now if you
recall show signup is using user slash
signup view and we're using the same
view in rerender signup as well so we're
going to modify the signup view to cater
for both cases of the showing the form
for the first time and also rerender in
the form with errors and existing form
information so let's go ahead and open
up views slash user slash signup that
bug to modify it and to use form data
and errors fields now let's take a look
at the first input field with the name
email we can pass back existing values
on an input field using the value
property so here for the value property
we're going to type form data that email
we could potentially populate the value
property of the password field as well
but we're not going to do that as
password is a sensitive field so let's
add error message information now and
let's create a new line under the first
input and let's type if errors and
there's that email which is the name for
the input field we're going to type P
dot small dot text danger these are
classes from bootstrap and we're going
to finally display the error message
errors of email if you recall we create
these messages in the validator function
let's do the same for the password field
so I'm going to create a new line under
the password input field and let's type
if errors and then errors dot password P
dot small dot text danger
there's the password now let's save our
file and we should be ready to try what
we've done so far now let's go back to
our browser window
go to the slash signup browse and I'm
going to type user at email com we know
that we have a user already with this
email address so let's see what happens
when we include that and for the
password I'm going to type full
character password which should also
trigger on there so if I click on sign
up I took it the form re-rendered with
the right error messages notice how the
validator has both detected that the
email is already in use we've done this
with the database query and the password
length was also detected to be not valid
that's checking all the changes we made
it adds validators we've added the new
directory validators and we've
implemented error and link and form
validation or signup routes in this
tutorial we're going to learn how to
implement access control in our
application also we will learn the
concept of a middleware and how to use
it in expressjs
the problem with our application in its
current form is that the leads link here
is open to public
anybody can click on this link view our
links or edit them and we're going to
fix that so let's open up our editor and
go to routes slash index dot JSP is a
significant property of route
definitions is that we can introduce a
sequence or a chain of function calls
before we make a call to the final
handler for that route let me show what
I mean with an example I'm going to
introduce a new call right after the
path component called novel and place a
comma and let's define not with constant
no equals function req res next and an
empty body as you recall the handlers in
expressjs have this particular function
signature where there is first a red
object and then a res object and the
next object and we've never made use of
this next object here so we're going to
make a call to next and leave it at that
what this does is that when the slash
leads path is match
the first function to be called is going
to be knob and knob will transfer
execution to the next one in line which
is show leads and the way we do that is
by making a call to next I could
potentially add additional knob calls
here and it will be all the same because
no op does nothing but transfer the
control of execution to the next one in
line in a route definition we have the
capability to add as many calls as we
need to any separate handlers before we
call the final Handler and this gives us
a lot of flexibility for adding
additional functionality to each route
and we're going to see one example
shortly before we move on I want to
demonstrate you that these no of course
indeed have no effect and we are able to
call show leads as normal so let's go to
our browser window and click on the
leads link and we're still able to see
the leads as usual now let's go back to
our editor window if you notice these
knob calls are in the middle when
handling the requests for this route
that's why they're called middleware
middleware may sound like a grant term
that does something complex but a
middleware can merely be a simple
function call such as this log function
and let's remember that in a middleware
function we always need to make a call
to next in order to precede the
execution to the next one in line and
make sure that the final handler gets
called now we're going to define a
really basic middleware first let's
delete this knob call and delete these
calls in the middle and let's create a
new folder called middleware in our root
directory and we're going to create a
new file called has off KS let's like
let's create error equals require HTTP
errors create error function allows us
to create an error object with an error
message and we've already made use of
this in app dot J's and it comes as
standard with the button like Express
J's installation so let's go back so
let's define a new method exports
is lured in equals function rec res next
if rec dot user then we will call next
the presence of rec that user means that
passport Jas has authenticated the user
there is a session and there's a logged
in user who is requesting the page so
we're allowed to go to the next step of
handling that page and else we're going
to create the error create error 404 and
we're going to give the message page
does not exist now there is one thing I
need to mention about how this next
works in the successful case we're
calling next to move on to the next
handler but in the error case we're also
calling next so how come we're showing
an error message or we call next which
should normally call the next handler
for this route while the answer is in
the Express documentation if you pass
anything to next function expressed
regards the current request as being an
error and it will skip any remaining non
error handling routing and middleware
functions what that means is we're going
to skip all the route handlers that are
coming next and we will go straight to
our error handler using the object we're
passing here and that error handler is
in app dot J's if you scroll down below
you will see this error handler already
defined for us when we pass an object
then that means that this error variable
will have that object being passed from
next and we're going to display an error
message and render the error page so
that describes how next will work in
most cases of a success and error let's
save this file and go to index dot J is
in the rouse folder and we're going to
import this function we have just
defined so let's type let is logged in
equals require dot dot middleware slash
has off J
and we're going to use it's logged in in
the leads route as our middleware so
let's type is logged in and then a comma
let's save this file and try our
application again so I'm logged out so
and I'm going to reload this page and
I'm going to click on leads let's see
what happens
indeed our middleware has found that the
page does not exist and generated a 404
error while we are at it I want to
beautify our error page as well so let's
go back to our editor and open up views
slash error that bug and I'm going to
copy and paste code that I prepared
earlier for this we're using a few
bootstrap classes let's save and reload
this page now this looks better just to
note we're ready to see exactly what
happened in the application and that's
because the application is running in
debug mode if we were running in the
production mode we wouldn't see this
error stack now just to demonstrate you
the other case let's go back to the
landing page and login I'm going to type
user at email cone and sign in now if I
click on leads I'm able to still see the
leads now every user has access to our
leads table so we're going to take our
access control concept a little further
and only allow a particular user to have
access to these pages so let's go back
to our editor and create a new migration
under migrations let's create a new file
with today's date we're going to add a
new field called is admin to the users
table I'm going to copy and paste code
that I prepared for this earlier and
let's go over it quickly so what we're
doing here is creating an easy admin
field which is a boolean and when it's
true we will consider the user as an
admin of our application and here we
have the up method for the migration
where we add the column to our table and
the down method which will remove this
column from our table called users but
save this file and go back to our
terminal and type sequel eyes DB migrate
so we've successfully migrated our table
and added an is admin boolean field to
our users table now let's go back to our
editor I'm going to make a modification
in the way we create new users let's go
to controller / UJS and the signup
handler now if there are no users in our
application with an admin flag as true
we're going to create the next user as
an admin and for that I'm going to
modify the signup handler let's type
return model's user find one where is
admin is true then user and if user
exists that means user not equal to null
then we're going to craft the user role
as normal so let's cut and paste the way
we creates the first user and else we're
going to create the user what the field
is admin equals true and for this to
work we need to first declare new user
outside use the new user variable and
finally we're going to save the user
back to our database so let's place this
after the else statement let's save this
file and check that our application is
running correctly what we haven't done
is update our model under models with
the es admin field so let's create an
easy admin field under here at the
bottom I'm going to copy and paste code
prepared for this earlier so is admin is
a boolean and we allow it to be now
because the existing users won't have a
this field set let's save our model file
and
go back to our browser and let's sign up
as a new user and I'm going to type
password for that and press sign up now
we have admin at email comm signed in
and let's go back to our terminal to
verify that this user was indeed created
with his admin as true insert into users
first second third and fourth field is
is admin and I can confirm that admin at
email comm is confirmed as an admin in
our application now we're ready to
implement the is admin check in our
middleware so let's go back to our
editor and go to middleware slash has
all J's and I'm going to define a new
function here exports but has off equals
function read press next and if rec user
is not mall and and rec user dot is
admin it's true then we're going to call
next as usual and allow access and else
we're going to create an error as before
next create error 404 page does not
exist let's save this and let's go back
to route slash index dot JSP
this new method has off and we're going
to replace the is logged in middleware
with this one
so let's light has off and save this and
open up our browser and let's reload
this page and I have the leads link here
if I click on this thing I'm still able
to see the leads and I'm going to log
out now and log in as another user that
I just signed up as which is no admin at
calm and login and if I now click on the
leads link
I am redirected to the page does not
exist error page so this effectively
demonstrates our use of the has out
middleware in order to control access to
certain pages on our application we now
want to extend this to other routes
where the leads are edited and accessed
so we're going to add the has out
middleware to other routes as well so
let's type has off for shortly as off
for the Edit lead and the rest now all
of our routes are protected by the has
Al's middleware except the first one
which is for visitors and the landing
page now let's check in our changes
let's type git add middleware if
migrations its comments - pay and
implement has of middleware and is admin
like lead routes are protected as and
only the admin user has access to them I
hope you enjoyed these tutorials my name
is brother I'm a system software
engineer my background is in low-level
software and operating systems if you
enjoyed these tutorials I want to be
notified of similar content in the
future you can go to this website and
join our community here if you scroll
down the low you will see a button to
join it's free thank you for watching
these tutorials and I hope to see you in
another tutorial in the future